there's such a
tremendous emotional scene when gaul is
saying goodbye to you
and i'm just curious what was it like
filming that scene because
it's it's really emotional and and she's
so great in it
um yeah we shot
that off of pennsylvania avenue like
we shot that um that day when we did
that huge part of that huge sea it was a
week long sequence but
you know running down pennsylvania
avenue and her running down
and then her last sewing up and we did
it in stages and we like went behind
um this pillar and uh did the scene and
uh you know it's a it's a really hard
scene
to do especially when there's a lot of
other stuff to do like
action and stuff like that in the rest
of the day
um and certainly really
emotional for her and patty's just very
good about a making sure we have the
space to
to really figure out the scene and make
it authentic
and then really pushing
us as actors to to get there and not
accepting anything less
than absolute truth so
it really i think was a credit to
gal for being so emotionally open and
patty for being such a
such a stickler